um
here is a sort of portrait in
the childish
nature
of the modern american right wing
as many of you know this phrase let's go
brandon has become yes a cringe-worthy
but a rallying cry nonetheless
for the american anti-biden right wing
let's go brandon if you're not familiar
with it there was a nascar driver named
brandon who was being interviewed after
a race
and the crowd was chanting f joe biden
but the reporter doing the interview
heard it as
let's go brandon instead of f joe biden
it's let let's go brandon so because it
was misheard now if you mean f joe biden
you say let's go brandon they've got
flags they've got shirts they've got all
sorts of merchandise of course it's
being monetized
it's it's not a good right wing meme
unless it's being monetized
joe biden and jill biden took phone
calls from people over the holiday to
say hello and to say you know different
things that was my phone that dropped um
and a guy got on the phone with joe
biden
and he actually said let's go brandon
and joe biden seemingly unaware of the
meme or at least choosing not to react
to it
um says yeah okay let's let's go brandon
and the right is absolutely
aroused and titillated by it they are
foaming at the mouth they think it's
great except now the guy who did it
jared schmeck is saying i was kidding
and it was just my free speech
and now i am being harassed so let's go
through the different elements of it
here is the video of this incident
taking place and joe biden seems to
either not care or not even be aware of
the meme
this isn't to you jared this is to the
kids i hope you have a wonderful
christmas
yeah i hope you guys have a wonderful
christmas as well
merry christmas and let's go brandon
let's go brandon i agree hey by the way
where are you in oregon
where's your home
i think we lost him
yeah okay so
it's very dumb i mean if this is the big
wow
payoff
it's a very very dumb payoff but the
right loved it here is donald trump jr
saying it's amazing and joe biden
doesn't know what's going on etc etc i
mean who would have thought joe biden
just gave guys like me the greatest
christmas present
ever
he has no idea what's going on folks so
i'm laughing and we're joking uh
and maybe this guy the guy who yelled
out the let's go brandon that guy's a
hero not all heroes wear capes unless
this guy's wearing a cape
which he should
uh absolutely amazing yeah so listen
first of all
if joe biden really didn't recognize
like let's assume joe biden's not doing
a poker face here let's assume he really
doesn't recognize the meme
i don't care
whether presidents are aware of the
memes about them and the jokes and the
insults about them i really don't care i
care about policy and i have many
criticisms of joe biden about policy
which i've made on the show but i don't
care if joe biden doesn't know about
this if he does and he just kept a poker
face that's even even funnier but the
really funny part at the end of the day
is the reaction from the guy who did it
jared schmeck
who is the guy that did this
claims he is quote being attacked for
utilizing my freedom of speech after he
essentially told the president to f
himself
the right loves to talk about tone
and demeanor
and behaving appropriately
and what the guy essentially did is tell
the president to to his face to go f
himself
if you have respect for the office
remember under george w bush oh even if
you don't agree with the specifics of
going to iraq you must respect the
office
it's another one of those values they
don't really care about uh now he sort
of says that he was kidding he says it
was just a joke i don't know what the
joke exactly is
and he says it was a reflection of his
frustration with biden's policies
including federal vaccine mandates
inflation and global supply supply chain
problems
when i watched that video it didn't seem
like when he said let's go brandon
that's what he was talking about schmeck
went on to say at the end of the day i
have nothing against mr biden but i am
frustrated because i think he could be
doing a better job schmeck is 35 and is
a former police officer now working for
the electrical company and says i mean
no disrespect to him
saying f you to the president
seems disrespectful if you're talking
about respect for the office he says i
understand there's a vulgar meaning but
i'm not that simple-minded no matter how
i feel about him
uh
just unbelievable unbelievable
um
it's uh it's another one of the oh he
clarified he's not a trumper but is a
free-thinking american and follower of
jesus christ and says i'm being attacked
for utilizing my freedom of speech
once again
freedom of speech doesn't mean freedom
from the consequences of that speech
when you go and tell the president to
his face to f himself
there may be people who don't like that
and that speech might have consequences
there's no violation of your first
amendment the government is not limiting
or abridging your your ability to speak
in any way but there simply may be
consequences so this was his big moment
donald he he got an atta boy from donald
trump jr and he's also getting a lot of
people responding and saying you know
that that was actually pretty lame
uh nobody has violated his ability to
speak in fact most people never get the
opportunity to say anything to the
president jared schmeck did and he said
let's go brandon
make of it what you will
we have a couple of actually i have like
four or five different things to tell
you about that are upcoming first of all
we have sent out dozens of free t-shirts
to viewers i made the offer a couple of
weeks ago if you grab a new full-priced
yearly membership on our website before
the end of the year i will send you a
free t-shirt for a while due to the
pandemic we were seeing major delays in
shipping t-shirts the delays seem to be
gone
dozens of free t-shirts have gone out so
if you want to take advantage of of
getting a free t-shirt
you can't be a an existing member this
is for new members you go to
joinpakman.com
you pay the full yearly price not
monthly and then after signing up email
info davidpakman.com i will personally
get that t-shirt out to you uh just got
to sign up by the end of the year number
two
on january 1st we are going to do a 2022
midterm kickoff special
it's going to be an insane membership
discount if you'd like to be notified
about it and to take advantage of it
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com that's number two number
three
the viewer town hall is rescheduled for
tomorrow why we wanted to do it a couple
weeks ago
when i was on the road my connection was
terrible we just couldn't make it happen
so it's rescheduled for tomorrow 6 pm
eastern on the pacman live youtube
channel
and then lastly we are also going to be
doing
the next or i guess first for 2022
david pakman show chess tournament if
you want to play in the chess tournament
these are great community events
everybody's welcome it's going to be
tuesday january 11th at 6 00 p.m eastern
i'll have more about that in the new
year but you can mark it on the calendar
the next chess tournament tuesday
january 11th 6 p.m eastern so we'll take
a quick break it's great to be back and
so much to talk with you about